colère dans les prisons 50 gardiens
révoqué après une journée d'agitation
dans une cinquantaine de centres en
direct dans un instant le directeur de
l'administration pénitentiaire le
gouvernement michel rocard en tête
accentue sa pression sur la direction de
peugeot incident à mulhouse où henri
krasucki encourager les grévistes les
conflits sociaux mais aussi l'évolution
à l'est georges marchais qui revient de
moscou est avec nous
la mort d'un dictateur ferdinand marcos
a while madame aquino un service le
rapatriement aux philippines de sa
dépouille madame monsieur bonsoir le
conflit des gardiens de prison s'est
embrasé depuis la nuit dernière 54
prison ont été aujourd'hui touchées par
la grève et dans plusieurs centrales
les forces de l'ordre ont dû intervenir
pour juguler la colère des détenus privé
entre autres de visites au parloir hier
l'administration pénitentiaire a décidé
de révoquer 50 gardiens de prison les
syndicats ne sont plus d'accord pour
négocier avec le garde des sceaux and
gas bergé nous raconte la journée la
journée dans les prisons françaises le
dialogue entre surveillants et forces de
l'ordre n'a tenu qu'à un seul mot les
parloirs
dès ce matin à fleury merogis 60
grévistes bloquaient l'entrée des
familles de détenus
la loi je vous demande de me disperser
non il va être celle de la force
il aurait pâti dernière fois et menaces
n'y feront rien quelques minutes plus
tard deux escadrons de gendarmes mobiles
interviennent les femmes de détenus
obtiennent finalement gain de cause
dialogue de sourds et affrontements
plusieurs fois répété au cours de la
journée à la prison de la santé les
surveillants de l'équipe de jour refuse
de prendre leur service sans crs sont
appelés en renfort à l'intérieur pour
garder les deux mille détenus la santé
ou tout s'emballe en début d'après midi
jean pierre dintilhac directeur de
l'administration pénitentiaire tient une
réunion de crise au nom du gouvernement
il somme les grévistes de reprendre leur
travail et brandi la menace de la
révocation mêmes sanctions évoquées à
lyon la direction des prisons de la
ville demande le renvoi définitif de
quarante cinq surveillants là encore
seule la présence des forces de l'ordre
a permis les parloirs dans toutes les
prisons de france
les gardiens ont indiqué qu'il
refuserait de prendre leur service ils
leurs collègues étaient sanctionnés nous
n'avons rien à perdre en tentons ici et
là dans cette escalade les syndicats
pourraient maintenant appelés à déposer
les clés le gouvernement n'aurait alors
de solution que d'utiliser la police
pour maintenir l'ordre
derrière les grilles et à fresnes il est
à moi d'une heure deux surveillants
étaient hébergés légèrement blessés
après l'intervention des forces de
l'ordre en fin d'après-midi place
vendôme à paris les dirigeants syndicaux
sont venus signifier le refus de
rencontrer le garde des sceaux rémy
roche et elle a visiblement ici place
vendôme on redoute est en tout cas on
attendait beaucoup de monde
il est vrai que l'évolution du mouvement
des surveillants va très nettement dans
le sens de la tension
en fait seuls sont venus les leaders des
organisations syndicales pour expliquer
à la presse pourquoi les révocations a
lancé interdisait tout dialogue et
quelles pourraient en être les
conséquences immédiates
s'il souhaitait une escalade fois qu'on
le dise demain matin mais l'annoncé des
hausses au soir il ya là nue qui risque
d'être très chaud je connais nos
camarades de la base si je suis persuadé
que ces versions loin de les leur faire
baisser les bras au contraire qu'on les
excite beaucoup d'encre est presque on
prépare du thé davantage de violence
dans les prisons m'expliquer je crois
que on a l'impression que certains ne
cherche demandons donc aux personnels
pénitentiaires de ne pas se rendre au
travail demain matin et de refuser de
pénétrer dans les détentions
il n'est pas normal de laisser punir
seulement 80 personnes nous sommes tous
responsables moi le premier je dois être
révoqué ils ont sans surveillants et
donc investi par les crs ou les gardes
mobiles
il faut remonter à 1974 pour retrouver
une situation identique
oui c'est la troisième fois en un an que
le personnel pénitentiaire exprime son
mécontentement en février dernier vous
en souvenez le mouvement avait duré un
mois sans que toutes les revendications
soient satisfaites
monsieur d'atiak bonsoir vous êtes né le
directeur de l'administration
pénitentiaire avait pris ni j'imagine et
à côté de vous dans votre bureau de la
place dont vous venez monsieur dintilhac
de révoquer 50 gardiens c'est la
sanction la plus lourde
ça veut dire que l'épreuve de force et
est véritablement engagé ce soir puis
l'épreuve de force
il s'agit pas véritablement d'une
épreuve de force et quart dans la
situation où l'on des il y a deux
problèmes un confit social est un
service public essentiel au
fonctionnement de l'état et je devrais
dire sans faire l'historique trop ancien
que c'est la première fois en 1989
sauf à remonter en 1957 que dans le
cadre d'un conflit social
les personnels pénitentiaires ont
utilisé le service public les
établissements pénitentiaires comme
enjeu dans leur conflit c'est sûr qu'il
ya une escalade dans les méthodes
employées par les syndicats bien sûr il
faut remonter je voulais indiqué à 1957
juillet 1957 ou d'ailleurs des
révocations avait été prononcée aussi
car il y aller
qui ne sont pas acceptables mais cela
étant dit qu'est ce que vous allez faire
parce que si les syndicats refusent de
négocier si les clés sont déposés par
les gardiens ça veut dire quoi que les
les forces de l'ordre que l'armée peut
être vont devoir investir les prisons
alors en deux mots la discussion
l'examen des problèmes a été fait à deux
reprises avec des résultats qui sont des
résultats importants je voudrais
indiquer ici que un surveillant
l'administration pénitentiaire gagne
environ 7000 francs en début de carrière
et un peu plus de dix mille francs en
fin de carrière qu'il a un régime très
favorable de retraite que les gains
résultant des derniers acteurs de
février et de septembre se sont traduits
par une amélioration de 300 à 500 francs
par fonctionnaire il ya donc eu des
discussions il ya eu des négociations il
ya eu les améliorations et le ministre
de la justice mme surveillant en
permanence à proposer et à demander et a
souhaité aux horizons professionnels de
venir les voir de les rencontrer
individuellement collectivement et ceux
ci ont toujours refusé
et là qu'ils ont osé ce vaisseau néfiach
ce soit pour empêcher quand même que la
nuit risque d'être à nouveau chaude
comme la nuit dernière alors sur le
service public c'est la priorité
actuellement il faut qu'il soit assuré
et si les fonctionnaires des 1500
pénitentiaire ne veulent pas l'assurer
ils le seront par les autres moyens et
notamment et par les fonctionnaires de
police et par les militaires de la
gendarmerie qui subiront c'est une
situation tout à fait normale et qui
d'ailleurs discrédite ceux des
fonctionnaires qui en même temps
demande une parité et une intègre une
intégrale it et de la parité avec les
fonctionnaires de police et donc vous
êtes vous êtes toujours quand même pour
l'ouverture de discussions l'invitation
de monsieur arpaillange reste restent
ouvertes soit les discussions les
discussions ont lieu en permanence et là
c'est un ultimatum et une escalade qui a
été fait avec le sentiment et ça c'est
inacceptable que l'on pouvait utiliser
s'approprier le service public
pénitentiaire
ce n'est pas régulier dans une
entreprise privée ce n'est pas
acceptable avec un service
public il appartient à tout le monde il
appartient à l'état
il est indispensable à son
fonctionnement il ne peut pas être
appropriées et intégrée dans le cadre
d'un compte dans le cadre d'un conflit
social je veux remercier l'autre confie
qui dure sans solution visible c'est
bien sûr le conflit peugeot lé premier
incident sérieux entre grévistes et non
grévistes ont eu lieu à mulhouse en
début d'après midi à l'occasion de la
visite d'henri krasucki sur place maryse
mano françois houtin il n'y avait pas
que des grévistes pour accueillir henri
krasucki et mulhouse
les cadres et agents de maîtrise
affichée très haut leur opinion sur
cette visite ils attendent à quelques
mètres du local syndical seul endroit de
l'entreprise ou henri krasucki pouvait
venir
ça c'est la loi
quelque chose il aurait volontiers des
réformes sans soutien légal à ceux qui
occupent la forge n'évite pourtant pas
l'incident à la sortie du secrétaire
général
les cadres et la maîtrise se pressent
autour d'une voiture de la cgt l'un
d'eux va tomber sur leucate pour
apparemment poussé par des mains non
identifié la cgt crie à la provocation
volontaire
les cadres dénonce la violence des
grévistes pourtant bien calme justice
mais ce soir l'homme l'exclure est
rentré chez lui cet incident ajoute
encore à la tension de la nuit dernière
ou des cadres et agents de maîtrise
harceler les grévistes qui occupent la
forge lançant des bombes fumigènes
provoquant un début d'incendié
heureusement vite éteint la maîtrise en
tan une guerre psychologique contre les
grévistes
mais cette guerre peut à tout moment
dégénérer dans la violence oui la jambe
pour maîtrise blessé en début
d'après-midi a pu quitter l'île tout à
l'heure l'hôpital le canard enchaîné ne
sera pas saisie
contrairement aux souhaits de monsieur
calvet ainsi on a décidé en fin de
journée le tribunal de paris qui ordonne
pourtant la publication dans le prochain
numéro du canard des protestations du
patron de peugeot la pression du
gouvernement sur la direction du groupe
s'accentuent
même si toute intervention directe sur
une entreprise privée est exclu le
ministre du travail jean pierre soisson
qui ici même l'autre soir avait déjà mis
en doute la légitimité de certains
licenciements envisagés
jean pierre soisson donc ce matin s'est
déclaré à nouveau prêt à jouer les
intermédiaires il a aussi insisté sur le
respect du droit du travail notamment en
ce qui concerne les intérimaires et les
représentants du personnel
le premier ministre michel rocard à lui
publiquement critiqué une nouvelle fois
l'entêtement de la direction de peugeot
il s'adressait à chartres aux
parlementaires socialistes qui vous le
savez ne ménagent pas leurs critiques à
l'encontre de sa politique
jean-michel mercurol bernard ap journée
parlementaire sur fond d'agitation
sociale un vrai dilemme pour les élus
socialistes
écartelé entre les choix du gouvernement
et les exigences de leur base électorale
grève des impôts plus de mansuétude
reviendrait à remettre en cause les
grandes priorités leur explique ce matin
michel rocard conflit peugeot il n'est
pas dans le rôle du gouvernement
d'intervenir et pend encore matignon
dépité bourgon les parlementaires
socialistes ne peuvent que modéré leurs
critiques et se rendre à l'évidence le
budget est ficelé et personne n'a trouvé
de solution alternative
ce que beaucoup d'entre vous ressentent
je crois que je me comprends fort bien
vous savez que ce que nous on va dans le
bon sens mais vous savez aussi qu'il
faut bien du temps
bien du temps et au même moment toutes
vos fibre socialiste se révoltent contre
le spectacle pour vous quotidien pour
moi aussi je suis maire il ya aussi
d'inégalités dans ma propre commune l'on
soit dans mes permanences le spectacle
quotidien d'injustice plus ou moins
grande d'absurdité plus ou moins graves
de détresse plus ou moins profondes
quand notre coeur des vite notre raison
des audiences de la ce sentiment un peu
trouble qui conduit quelques-uns avec
tiff ou d'autres les plus nombreux aux
doutes ou à la frustration appel à la
raison d'aucuns pensent et surtout
résignation voilà pourquoi sans doute
devant les parlementaires déboussolés
michel rocard a tenu à associer le nom
de françois mitterrand à sa propre
démarche de lutte contre les inégalités
monsieur marché bonsoir bonsoir on
imagine bien que sur le fond vous êtes
d'accord avec henri krasucki en ce qui
concerne le conflit peugeot sur le plan
politique quand même est ce que vous
vous considérez comme l'a dit hier
monsieur krasucki qu'il n'y a aucune
différence entre la méthode calvet et la
méthode roquain oui je crois que le
discours de michel rocard aujourd'hui
dont j'ai eu connaissance confirme tout
à fait cette chose tout d'abord et j'ai
retenu trois idées la première c'est
qu'il dit nous ne sommes pas concernés
par le conflit peugeot c'est un conflit
dans le secteur privé
nous ne sommes pas concernés ans dans le
gouvernement
deuxième chose qu'il a
avant c 'est concernant la lutte que
mènent les travailleurs des impôts qui
eux appartiennent au secteur public
oui il a reproduit non à la
revendication est la troisième chose
concernant vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure les gardiens de prison à
laquelle il à l'égard duquel il a pris
des mesures et précis puisque 50 ont été
licenciés quelles conclusions politiques
chez dba politique
je tire de cette situation c'est que
michel rocard ne veut pas à tenir compte
que sa politique provoque dans le pays à
mécontente minc qui touche différentes
couches sociales et un mécontentement
qui ne cesse de s'accroître en intense
une politique de concertation on peut
quand même pas nier qu'il ya une
concertation notamment dans le web ou à
l'est où est la considération des
discussions monsieur marché mais par
exemple ou et la concertation
chez peugeot y a pas de concertation
chez peugeot d'ailleurs ça ne veut pas
ça on est bien d'accord mais j'essayais
de voir justement que la méthode du
gouvernement n'est pas celle mais la red
bull le problème le problème politique
et les suivants c'est qu'en définitive
entre la méthode du patronat
calvet et la méthode gouvernementale
michel rocard il y à une convergence
réelle
au fond le gouvernement ne veut pas
céder ne veut pas dire gossier
sérieusement les revendications avec les
fonctionnaires pris globalement un prix
globalement il veut pas négocier avec
eux et satisfaire leurs revendications
et calvet qui représente le patronat
privé le patronat lui 900 groupes sony
et il représente le patronat le cnpf
puis là il a l'appui du cnpf
il ne peut pas lui non plus négocier
autrement dit ils s'épaulent
mutuellement et ils s'épaulent
mutuellement pour refuser une
revendication sérieux une
discussion sérieuse permettant d'aboutir
à des négociations et faire avancer les
revendications alors politique de
rigueur absolument mais c'est la
politique de rigueur du gouvernement qui
est précisément responsable de la
situation que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui
ben ouais je vous donne un exemple mais
vous venez déjà d'en donner quelques
temps un seul exemple tu permets qu'on
pourrait régler les conflits
à l'assemblée nationale il ya une
majorité de gauche jean yves cousin 17
jours à propos dans cette majorité nous
puis nous il y à une majeure socialistes
et communistes ont la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale dont vous êtes les
syndicats les syndicats demandent une
augmentation du smic
la cgt la concernant demande le smig à
6500 points
c'est aussi notre position est bien
pourquoi michel rocard pourquoi le
gouvernement ne soumettent il pas à
l'assemblée nationale la proposition de
passer le smig à 6500 francs
mais le conflit peugeot serait réglée
alors qu'on ne me dise pas que 6500
francs de smic ce n'est pas possible
parce que cela représente le quart des
profits réalisés par les patrons
monsieur marché est ce que ça veut dire
que vous cédiez la première occasion à
l'assemblée de voter la censure contre
le gouvernement requérants me sens en
particulier au projet de loi sur le
financement des jeux viennent dire la
verse
c'était bien dire linverse j'ai bien
conscience et j'en ai de multiples échos
que parmi les travailleurs socialistes
et militants du parti socialiste il y a
de l'inquiétude et du mécontentement et
moi je m'adresse elle et je leur dis
assez à ces gens je vous comprends je
vous comprends
et nous ne sommes pas nous n'avons pas
la prétention où la volonté d'utiliser
les grèves et les conflits à des fins
politiciennes absolument pas donc ça
c'est plutôt rations pour absolument oui
mais je leur dise je dis ceci je dis ce
qu'il faut c'est précisément revenir à
une politique de gauche
et si le gouvernement de michel rocard
revenait à une politique de gauche
examine
d'une manière sérieuse des
revendications des travailleurs
et bien il y aura une majorité à
l'assemblée nationale pour satisfaire
des revendications telles celles du smig
à 6500 francs écouté hier soir j'ai
regardé sur votre chaîne l'émission
s'appelle place publique oui cette avait
claude sérillon ça ici dit un dirigeant
sur peugeot
c'était une émission remarquable tout à
fait remarquable jeudi bouleversante
bouleversante à la fois par les deux
petits films qui avaient été réalisés
sur le terrain et bouleversante par le
débat qui a eu lieu entre les
représentants de peugeot et un certain
nombre de personnalités non non et j'ai
la trentaine de jeux je vais m'en
félicite service public ça service
public ni alors quelques je crois que
les téléspectateurs qui ont vu cette
émission n'ont pas pu ne pas être
profondément plus le versés par ces
familles expliquant qu'avec 4800 francs
par mois
on ne peut pas vivre on survit mais on
ne vit pas par conséquent le problème de
l'augmentation des salaires en prenant
sur les profits capitalistes
il y a de l'argent tout le monde le dit
la situation est meilleure
il y a de l'argent les entreprises font
des profits
eh bien il faut que le gouvernement
change de politique
et s'il change de politique alors oui
communiste nous sommes tout à fait
disponible alors revenant ans
précisément un autre conflit ou qu'elle
vous faisait allusion tout à l'heure à
profit dans le secteur public celui là
il s'agit des agents des finances il
durcit il durcit sérieusement malgré
l'appel au sang-froid lancée par pierre
bérégovoy manifestations et incidents
aujourd'hui un peu partout en france
jean-pierre mitigé
va donc désormais général ou impôts
pratiquement tous les départements ont
basculé dans la grève une grève de
harcèlement quotidien des agents du fisc
ici explications dans les gares
parisiennes ce matin blocage du tgv
amante le conflit porte sur les salaires
mais aussi sur les effectifs
on a fait un recensement dans le val de
marne par exemple moment que 183 jambes
ça veut dire que le service public qui
peut plus être assuré
on a supprimé les postes d'accueil ça
veut dire que la fraude fiscale est
encore pire qu'avant ça veut dire que
c'est toujours les petits salariés qui
payent un que les grosses boîtes elles
peuvent pas de vérifier en province on
réclamait des négociations la première
et dernière remonte au 5 septembre
il en était sorti une prime de 2200
francs depuis le conflit n'a cessé de
s'étendre et les grévistes envisagent
même de bloquer la paye des ministres
oui alors monsieur marchait vous rentrez
de moscou à l'est une telle chose
n'était évidemment pas envisageable est
ce que est ce que ça veut dire que tout
va mieux décidément à l'aise en plus
alors une telle chose et est tout à fait
envisageable bloquerait la paix des
ministres non aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que
de me fait ces gens là ils revendiquent
ils manifestent ils font la grève
et bien il y as en union soviétique
effectivement dans dans différents
secteurs d des revendications et il ya
des grèves ou les travailleurs expriment
leur volonté de voir changer les choses
qu'est ce qui est nouveau
ab so lu ment d'union soviétique
aujourd'hui est tout à fait
méconnaissable par rapport à ce qu'elle
était il ya cinq ans et vous êtes un
expert et chez jeu auquel est la
signification de ce vous connaissez bien
l'union soviétique vous connaissez bien
son système avec une banque je peux
l'union soviétique
j'y suis allé pour la première fois en
1959 et a fait 30 ans par conséquent je
peux prendre je peux témoigner
aujourd'hui il y en union soviétique
un immense chantier un immense chantier
mais naturellement un chantier avec une
direction qui s'est précisément quels
types d'immeubles
elle veut construire alors sans cesse
quand même ce qui est un peu surprenant
dans vos propos parce que j'ai lu
attentivement l'humanité de bière comme
seulement 10 des matériaux oui alors
vous dites la pérestroïka est
parfaitement maîtrisée ce n'est vraiment
pas ce que nous a dit ici à antenne 2
monsieur gorbatchev il ya il y a
quelques mois et ce n'est pas ce que
répètent les dirigeants soviétiques qui
qui disent qu'ils reconnaissent et ça
aussi c'est nouveau vous l'admettrez que
c'est très difficile fut long mais vous
confondez de choses ah parce que je dis
moi je tire deux enseignements de mon
voyage
le premier c'est que précisément la
direction soviétique
elle sait où elle veut aller à ici on
pensait sans doute quelques que l'union
soviétique allait revenir au capitalisme
qu'on va job dit non ce que nous voulons
ce n'est pas moins socialiste s'est
davantage de socialistes mais met alors
à une curieuse forme de socialisme ont
un peu l'impression que le capitalisme
devient le stade ultime du socialisme
quand on voit à la hongrie qui va mener
une économie de marché
la pologne et même l'union soviétique
mêlant chez soi quand même des
changements qu'on se ménageait pas tous
les problèmes
si vous aviez les ce biais des
soviétiques qui regarde ce qu'est la
situation aujourd'hui chez peugeot ou
chez les fonctionnaires ou dans les
gardiens de prison vous croyez que si il
aurait le souhait de venir à la société
capitaliste
non écoutez moi je très brièvement n'ont
pas beaucoup le temps mais moi je tire
deux enseignements qui sont tout à fait
indiscutable pour toute personne qui
veut qui va sur place et qui veut voir
c'est que les soviétiques et c'est
pourquoi il ya nulle contradiction entre
ce que monsieur gorbatchev vous a dit
ici ce qu'il m'a dit à moi je considère
qu'il maîtrise bien la situation
ils veulent une société socialiste
nouvelle une société socialiste moderne
une société pour l'homme et par l'homme
ça c'est incontestable avec avec un
parti communiste qui s'acquitte de ses
responsabilités dans la direction des
marchés quand vous dites on voit les
greffes chez nous ils n'ont vraiment pas
envie de ça vous avouerez quand même que
les allemands de l'est y sont en train
de voter avec leurs pieds de gueule moi
je veux bien mais c'est en bar l'union
sovétique allemagne de l'est hongrie
pologne c'est le même
non non non non non je moi je reviens
d'union soviétique et c'est de ça dont
je peux vous parler
la deuxième chose je crois qu'il faut
retenir c'est que effectivement et j'ai
utilisé le mot et les utiliser après
avoir beaucoup réfléchi réfléchi
l'entreprise est titanesque titanesque
pourquoi parce que il y a des acquis
c'est incontestable heins pas les
ardeurs des reculs sont les travaux de
titan à bouilhou pouvait bon peut encore
que les travaux d'hercule de ya une
différence c'est que des travaux
d'hercule de michel rocard ne sont pas
destinés à servir les intérêts des
travailleurs
alors que les travaux titanesques de de
mikhaïl gorbatchev sont destinés eux à
une société socialiste moderne adaptée à
l'époque que nous vivons
et c'est naturellement sa soeur à des
difficultés il n'avait pas prévu ils le
disent eux-mêmes dès le départ la
profondeur des réformes économiques
sociales démocratiques auxquelles il
fallait juste et non monsieur marche
aide d'un mot bon vous dites que vous
êtes maintenant tout à fait partisan
envoie votre en toute transparence en
ligne on sait vraiment pourquoi vous
dites maintenant et non mais ça veut
dire que ton pendant de très longues
années vous avez dû beaucoup souffrir
alors absolument et nous l'avons écrit
et nous l'avons dit avant tout au long
des quads et des 30 dernières années
d'observation non honnêtement non pas
des trente dernières années
pas des 30 dernières années des verts
mais depuis le depuis 1972
nous avons époque où nous avons
catégoriquement renoncé à l'idée qu'il
pouvait exister un modèle de société
socialiste
eh bien nous avons formulé nos critiques
nous remarque et je dirais même nos
exigences
nous avons nous avons de multiples
documents qui témoignent que le parti
communiste français n'a cessé de
demander des réformes à la fois je
répète démocratique ce économique
sociale et démocratique
d'ailleurs écouté j'ai rencontré
les journalistes comme vous à moscou
j'ai fait une conférence de presse alors
il y en avait il était un peu comme vous
un peu sceptique a alors oui les
soviétiques 90 des français non des
français des français pai soviétique
parce que les soviétiques ils savent que
ils connaissent j'étais six ans sans
aller en union soviétique
parce que nous avions un désaccord
fondamental à l'époque avec le parti
communiste de l'union soviétique sur la
conception de la société socialiste donc
mais ses journalistes dont nous parlons
là il avait développé aux idées
d'ailleurs qu'on entend chez nous à
savoir mais voyons marché teatrali vous
vous rendez vous vous vous ralliez à la
pérestroïka vous venez après alors je
leur ai fait une proposition
ils étaient une quinzaine je vous parie
une caisse de bouteilles de champagne si
vous trouvez dans mes discours
un seul mot texte disant que je ne suis
pas d'accord avec la pérestroïka soit
deux mois soit des dirigeants de mon
parti je vous paye à chacun d'entre vous
une caisse de bouteilles de champagne
mais la paille français mais si vous ne
pourrez si vous ne trouvez pas c'est
vous qui me perez champagne et bien
aucun de ses journalistes n'a voulu
parier
et pour cause parce que les faits sont
là alors un dernier mot parce qu'il faut
être savoir est modeste
ça ne l'est bref si vous ça ne veut pas
dire que nous avions tout prévu que nous
savons dans le détail comment il faut
faire comment il faut avancer
ge et que je termine par où j'ai
commencé
cet anime en chantier mais en s'appuyant
sur les acquis du socialisme
j'ai la conviction profonde qu'on va
vers le socialisme moderne adopté adapté
à l'époque que nous vivons aujourd'hui
monsieur marché merci pour cette
profession de foi 21 ans de pouvoir
trois ans d'exil huit mois d'agonie
ferdinand marcos président dictateur des
philippines jusqu'en 86 est mort
aujourd'hui à hawaï dans l'intérêt de la
sécurité du pays pas question de
rapatrier sa dépouille a déclaré tout à
l'heure le président des philippines
madame
kino michel mompontet ferdinand marcos
avait trois ambitions qui lui tenait à
coeur
trois images qu'ils voulaient gravé dans
l'histoire mais les philippins en ont
décidé tout autrement
l'image de lui-même qui le flattent est
le plus c'est bien sûr tout d'abord
celle ci marque aux le triomphant marque
aux qui par sa seule force incarnée à
tout jamais l'histoire glorieuse des
philippines marque aux houles et être le
battant vigoureux et viril le séducteur
irrésistible qui gagnait tout est
toujours en fait les philippins
garderont d'abord de lui une toute autre
image
un vieillard en exil qui n'en finit pas
de mourir un ex dictateur en décrépitude
symbole de saison de répression
heureusement révolue une déchéance
physique inexorable bien loin de son
machisme triomphant dans le temps marcos
et mais aussi par dessus tout exhiber
ses blessures de guerre vont dès son
patriotisme son amour du pays
là aussi l'histoire l'a pris à contre
pied les philippins ne se rappelleront
que de ces milliards de dollars extorqué
au pays des 10000 robes des 2600 paire
de chaussures d'imelda son épouse des
bijoux des tableaux volés aux musées
nationaux
ferdinand marcos houlette enfin et
c'était là sa troisième ambition
retourner avant de mourir aux
philippines il est mort ce matin
bien loin de son pays est encore plus
loin de son peuple
la foule se pressait en l'église de la
madeleine cet après-midi à paris pour
rendre un dernier hommage aux victimes
du dc 10 d'uta au premier rang le chef
de l'état et le premier ministre louis
carzou près de 4000 personnes ont
assisté cet après midi à la messe
célébrée en la mémoire des victimes du
dc 10 d'uta
le pape jean paul ii a adressé un
message de sympathie aux familles des
victimes de l'attentât du 19 septembre a
coûté la vie à 171 personnes
le sénateur des chars en pierre lacour
inculpé de recel dans une affaire de
fausses factures le sénateur aurait
touché des pots-de-vin d'une société
marseillaise de travaux publics
réélue dimanche dernier pierre la cour
était membre de la commission nationale
de l'urbanisme
la yougoslavie menacée d'éclatement par
la crise séparatiste en slovénie le
parlement de cette république a adopté
hier soir le droit de faire sécession
cette mesure a été immédiatement
déclarée inconstitutionnelle par les
autorités fédérales de belgrade
andréas papandréou devra comparaître une
seconde fois devant une cour spéciale
le parlement grec a décidé la traduction
de l'ancien premier ministre pour une
affaire de détournement de fonds plus
d'un milliard de francs au total
andréas papandréou avait déjà été
inculpé pour des écoutes téléphoniques
illégales
le marché a retrouvé un peu de santé
aujourd'hui avec de nouvelles rumeurs de
paix à la séance à paris s'est achevée
sur une progression de 0 14%
même chose du côté du dollar à 6 francs
39 50 au fixing une dernière image et du
vent dans les voiles à l'arrivée de la
première étape de la course autour du
monde en équipage victoire du néo
zélandais steyn la guerre sur son grand
ketch rouge
il a navigué en tête tout au long
pratiquement des onze mille trois cents
kilomètres séparant 500 tonnes en
angleterre de lure voyais temps de
traverser 25 jours
20h45 il a plus de 24 heures d'avancé
sur pierre fehlmann et son mérite
le premier français alain gabet sur
charles jourdan n'est qu'en 11e position
voilà et comme monsieur marché était
décidément très en verve j'ai tout juste
le cas encore de vous donner les
rapports du kart idées et du tiercé qui
se sont courues à maisons-laffitte donc
à l'arrivée le 13 le 18 le 7e 19 5
francs dans l'ordre 433 milles 550 550
dans un ordre différent 25 1898 francs
50 voilà et les rapports du trc dont 13
18 7 500 apporte 11600 20 francs 50 et
dans un ordre différent 2279 francs
voilà merci d'avoir suivi ce journal
dans un instant de la météo avec laurent
cabrol dernier journal tout à l'heure
avec en sagnier admirateurs
à